Tim: Thank you Heather MacDonald. Thank you
for heroically persevering. Before introducing
our next speaker, I would like to remind all
of you to visit the Hillsdale College literature
table. There you will find several college
publications including Imprimis. We're nearing
2.9 million monthly subscribers and growing
quickly.
You will also find information about the many
on and off campus lecture programs sponsored
by the college as well as our online education
courses. We're getting ready to release 2
new courses: A Proper Understanding of K12
Education: Theory In Practice and the other
is The Federalist Papers. You can sign up
for these courses and watch archived courses
for free. Just visit our website and you can
see courses on economics, politics, literature
and history among other topics.
I would also invite you to pick up a brochure
for the next Hillsdale College cruise, which
will sail this summer from Lisbon to London
aboard the Six Star Crystal Serenity. Don't
delay. We'll be packing up the literature
right after lunch. The more you take, the
less we have to take home with us.
I had the privilege of meeting our next speaker
and his lovely wife Penny when I came to Claremont,
California, in August of 1994 fresh from Hillsdale
College and ready to study for my PhD in political
science. At the time, he was the president
of the Claremont Institute. He didn't offer
any formal classes back then, as he does now,
but he did a lot of teaching anyway informally,
so I learned a lot from him about statesmanship
and political philosophy, whether in informal
conversations or listening to his speeches.
Back then, when he was the president of the
institute, I used to think he was a college
professor trapped in a think tank president's
body. Now I think he's a college professor
trapped in a college president's body. Of
course, all joking aside, those 2 things go
together at Hillsdale, as they used to in
most other ... Well, at all colleges and universities
until recent times.
Anyway, our students are fortunate to have
him as a professor and a president, I count
it as a privilege to have been able to work
with him now for 15 years plus, I think, or
almost 15 years at Hillsdale College. He will
be speaking today on the topic Conservatism
and Constitutionalism. Please welcome the
twelfth president of Hillsdale College, Dr.
Larry P. Arnn.
Larry: That Tim is tall, isn't he? Thank you
Tim. Thank you for being here. Wasn't Heather
heroic? I'm thinking about my maturity this
week because it's present, but also I've watched
Larry Kudlow become a gentle human being.
He's always been brilliant and always been
good, but now he's nice. I've watched Heather
grow up and become a power. That was really
great. I thank them both.
Doug Jeffrey always picks these topics, and
they always call up the speakers and tell
them what to say. They never do that with
me. They just assign me a topic. I don't know
if they figure I'll say whatever I please
or if they figure we've worked together so
long and studied together so long, I'll know
exactly what they mean. I always have confidence
about that, except last night Doug broke into
verse, so I don't know what's going on with
the boy and I don't know what he wants me
to do.
I'll tell you what I will do, I'm to talk
about Conservatism and Constitutionalism,
and that's a problem. There's something interesting
about that. The constitution is one of the
greatest liberal documents in human history.
The greatest living ... The great constitution.
The greatest written constitution by far.
There isn't anything close to it to last so
long, do so much.
The principles behind it, expressed in the
Declaration of Independence are fundamentally
important, and they are the most beautiful
political principles ever written. They're
not conservative in their nature. The word
liberal comes from the word free. Why aren't
we liberals? I'm going to try to explain that.
I'm going to explain it mainly by talking
about 2 people. They are teachers of mine
and they have both died in the last 6 weeks.
One of them is Harry Jaffa, a student of Aristotle
and Abraham Lincoln, Winston Churchill, Thomas
Aquinas, Shakespeare, a great teacher of political
philosophy. He wrote Barry Goldwater's "Extremism
in the defense of liberty" speech.
The other is Sir Martin Gilbert. Sir Martin
Gilbert is ... Was - he died just 2 weeks
ago. He was the official biographer of Winston
Churchill. He wrote 88 serious books of history.
These 2 men have a very great deal to do with
this question of the disposition of conservatives
to constitutions and to the American Constitution
because one of them did a very great act of
recovery, which I will describe to you. The
other one did the same.
The first one a recovery of the thinking and
meaning of the American Revolution and the
second one of the life and career of Winston
Churchill. I've been studying Winston Churchill
for a long time.
These 2 men, I should tell you, they were
incredibly sophisticated, influential in my
life and sophisticated people. We have the
papers of both of them at Hillsdale College
now. I met my wife, the aforementioned Penny
back there, the mother of our children, working
in the home of Martin Gilbert a long time
ago in Oxford.
Since Harry Jaffa introduced me to Martin
Gilbert and Martin Gilbert introduced me to
Penny, they can both take credit for my marriage
and felt that I owed them everything and would
say so. I'd acknowledge the fact. Mr. Jaffa,
who was more personally assertive than Martin
Gilbert, would also take credit for my children.
I would say, "You know, but she did that."
They would say, "Yeah, but how did you meet
her?"
This is a significant thing and both of them
are crucial to understanding where we are
in the world today in my opinion. Let me say
where that is. Heather just described a crisis.
By the way, she's a very intelligent young
woman, and she just gets better with every
passing year, which means that her character
is good. I've known her a long time and watched
her talk for a long time. I never saw her
do better than she did today.
I expect in a year or 2, when I see her again,
she'll do better yet. She's that sort. She
hinted at some element of despair at the end.
These problems are very deep. They are what
I said last night. The principle of self rule,
the principle that all men are created equal
focuses on this simple thing. Some of us are
smarter than others and some of us are taller
than others and some of us are richer than
others, but we've all got this one thing and
it makes us human. We can talk.
Studying with Professor Jaffa 400 years ago,
it was an electric experience because I studied
with a student of his by accident in undergraduate
school. I'm not a lawyer. I love to say I
didn't do that. I decided to get an education.
Professor Jaffa was not a really great teacher.
He was disordered and self-centered.
The first time I met him summer of 74, I was
given the great honor of going to pick him
up to take him to go to the first class. Peter
Schramm, my brother-in-law, took me. There,
we walk in the thing, and I'm going to meet
this great man, author of the Goldwater speech,
author of the best book about Abraham Lincoln,
and he appears in his boxer shorts.
He can't remember who I am and he can't remember
what the class is we're going to have. I think
to myself, "Golly gosh, what have I done?"
I'm just a kid too, so I didn't expect red
carpets or anything. I just thought maybe
he would recognize that I had corresponded
with him. I can remember the first thing he
said in class and it bears on this point,
what it is that makes us human.
He started the first class, and he hadn't
prepared in any way, except by his whole life.
The class was on Aristotle's Nicomachean Ethics,
which I teach now and which I read. I can't
tell you how many times I've read it, but
I think it might be once a year since 1974.
I know it pretty well.
Here's how he starts the class. He says, "When
people get old like me, they make a list of
the 100 greatest books, but that's foolish
because nobody lives long enough to master
100 great books. Can't be done. I have a list
of the 3 greatest books." What follows is
a little cryptic. I've thought about it for
years. I remember every word of it, and it
was what? 41 years ago.
He said, "Aristotle's politics would require
some translation to be fully relevant to modern
times. It sounds like he's excluding it."
He said, "The Bible is its own kind of thing."
Maybe he was was excluding it. Plato's Republic
would be on any such list.
He said the word Shakespeare. It hung in the
air for a while and he said, "Socrates said
that a poet would arise that could write both
tragedy and comedy. Seems to include Shakespeare."
Certainly, I know he did. Then he held up
the Ethics and he said, "This is a perfect
book, and we are going to read this book.
We are going to find out what we are."
Not everything in class was as good as that
with him because, as I say, he was disordered.
He was just brilliant, but it would happen
2 or 3 times a term out of 15 that he would
start explaining something fundamental to
you. My favorite thing - I heard him explain
it many times - was what it is human beings
can do that makes them human. Can talk is
the short answer. It's actually true that
because we can talk, it means we can ... How
do you give a name to a thing?
How do you know it's a bottle because there's
many bottles. They look all different, but
once you can recognize that that's a bottle,
you can use the term bottle. Professor Jaffa
referred to this as the miracle of the common
noun. You can never explain how you can do
it. Man, man, man, woman, woman, woman, they're
all different. Yet, in an instant, you can
see what they are and gives them a name. Once
you can give them a name, you can communicate
in a radically different way than any other
being.
Aristotle says animals ... It's in the politics.
He says, "Animals use their voices to indicate
pleasure and pain, but human beings use theirs
to describe the just and the unjust, the advantageous
and the disadvantageous." Do you see how we
do that about the just and the unjust? If
this is a bottle, then it's in a category
of things, and it would need to be treated
according to this category.
That phenomenon is vitally important because
you can eat a pig, but you can't eat a human
being. That's because you can know the difference
between them. They have different natures,
and they're indicated to be treated in different
ways. That's how justice arise. You learn
this from Professor Jaffa.
He loved the Declaration of Independence because
he said that your rights are written in that
capacity. They don't matter how smart you
are or how much money you've got or who your
parents were or what color you are. If you
can do that thing, then you are entitled to
all the rights of the human being. From that
fact grows these tremendous things.
I grew up in Arkansas, and my dad was a school
teacher and a learned man, only one in his
generation or before to go to college. I didn't
think he was wise until I became mature because
I was too stupid, but now I remember what
I learned from him. I didn't know I was learning.
Heather said boys need their daddies and their
mothers. I didn't remember ... I didn't know
I was learning these things from him, and
I was good at learning. I got really good
grades.
I know how I was raised. I was raised to think
that it didn't matter anything except that
I was a human being and was supposed to be
a good one. Everything hinged on whether I
did that or not. I was born to do whatever
I could do. I always thought I could do a
lot. We didn't have any money. We lived in
a little town in Arkansas. There were creditors
and stuff. I just thought that's how everybody
lived.
I had a friend that ... I still have him.
His son is graduating from our college. He's
a medical doctor now. I thought he was rich.
I know what it is to be rich. I know what
it is to be rich now. I always thought, by
the way, I was going to be rich. I am now
what I thought I was going to be. I just know
now it's not rich. There probably are some
rich people in this room, but I happen to
know most of you are not really rich. You're
just generous. Thank you.
That stuff. Grew up in America, you learn
to love that stuff. That's what's being taken
away. Harry Jaffa is the one who started the
movement to make the modern conservative movement
understand the greatness of all that stuff
because in the beginning, the conservative
movement which started in the late 40s and
50s, it was all about German economists ... They're
good too. I love them ... And about all kinds
of things, but it wasn't on about the Declaration
of Independence and the constitution, the
substance of American citizenship.
That was because a lot of those people suspected
that those things were not good things because
the account on the right when I started graduate
school of the American founding was that it
was a low solid thing. It was as good as you
could get in the modern world. Harry Jaffa
is the one who thought that through and saw
not.
I'll tell you how he did it. I happened to
be there. The turn came in the summer of 1976.
I was a student there, and I really wanted
to learn from him. The other students did
too, but I was so radical about it, that I
took up bicycle racing. I've ridden a bicycle
25,000 miles. Why? Because he did it and you
could be around him all the time, and you
could get him to answer your flipping questions,
which in class sometimes you couldn't get
him to do.
I would go over every summer. He was writing
an attack on a conservative man Irving Kristol
because Irving Kristol had written this thing
about how the American Revolution is low,
but solid. Professor Jaffa, for the first
time he'd been reading Lincoln. He'd started
reading it for himself, and what did he find?
Did you ever hear this story of George Washington
at the Battle of Monmouth, at the Battle of
Princeton? It's like a story about Achilles
except maybe better.
Marching his horse at the British at Princeton,
not knowing whether anybody was coming with
him, riding through American troops being
routed. If they had been routed, it would
have destroyed the advantage of the victory
at Trenton. Then we could have closed the
first year of the Revolutionary War without
anything looking like victory. Had to win.
Then he heard. He took Trenton, just miracle.
They were drunk and asleep.
He had to preserve it because he thought,
"We've got to win something." He'd said to
somebody that morning, George Washington,
"We'll be dead by nightfall anyway." "We've
got to go ahead. We're late," said the guy
... What's his name? Clover. A New Englander,
who is good at boats, he said, "General, we're
late. You said we had to be there by dawn."
Washington said to him, "Go ahead. It doesn't
matter. We'll be dead by nightfall if we don't
win today anyway."
Then the next day they had to go up to Princeton.
He gets there, and they're running, and he
just walks through them. He doesn't say anything
to them. He was a very big man, very beautiful
man. Fitzwilliam, his adjutant, records the
story. He gets close to the British. There's
an exchange of fire. Fitzwilliam says he covers
up his face with his hat. He couldn't bear
to look upon the destroyed George Washington.
George Washington was a tremendous horseman.
When the smoke cleared, Fitzwilliam looks,
and he sees that he's sitting on his horse
just as he was and making the same steady
progress that he was. There's been a volley.
He's been right in the middle of it, and he's
still going. The Americans have formed up
behind him without him saying anything to
them. The British run away. That man was picked
to be the President of the United States.
You couldn't call the constitutional convention
... Never mind that Alexander Hamilton and
James Madison are alive, Thomas Jefferson
is alive, and they're all working on it, Jefferson
from Paris. Never mind that. If Washington
won't go, that man won't go, it can't be done.
The reason is he is a picture of the moral
virtues, one of the greatest in all of history.
That means then all of a sudden ... Harry
Jaffa more than anybody else is the fellow
who discovered this. I happened to be there
when he did it. What a privilege, the excitement
of it. He'd delivered his paper, an attack
on a bunch of conservatives who had written
that America is corrupt and low and you can't
expect much from it, but by golly we like
it because it would be a lot worse if it was
communist. That was their argument.
I watched 400 people at the American Political
Science Association in 1976 come into the
room for this argument. I watched my teacher
wipe the floor with them. I learned my belligerence
at the hands of a master.
I got a Rotary fellowship, and Professor Jaffa
had met this man, Martin Gilbert, young then,
the official biographer of Winston Churchill.
The great Churchill Papers were in Oxford
and only to be used by him, which I didn't
know at the time, but soon learned had the
whole world of strands up in arms against
Martin Gilbert because, A, he was hogging
these papers and, B, he didn't write his books
about them and their books. He wrote the book
out of the original source documents.
I met him in the coffee shop. Professor Jaffa
had done him a favor so he had to meet me.
I had this fancy fellowship to go study in
England. I can remember every word that was
spoken. He was like a little ... He didn't
look like ... I thought he would look like
Neville Chamberlain. You should see a picture
of him. He's a little Jewish guy, very bright,
very powerful, tremendous conversationalist.
I meet him, and I'm young and stupid, so what
I should have said was, "I want to work on
the Churchill Papers," but I didn't think
that I did. I thought, "I'm going to write
a doctoral thesis about Churchill's political
thought. That's to be found best in published
sources. I don't need it." In a great kindness,
he said, "Can I help you?"
We had met, by the way, in a library called
the Wiener Library up close to Regent Park.
That's a library where some little Jewish
ladies keep a bunch of Nazi books. He was
looking at one when I first walked up beside
him. It was open, and it was a children's
book, a school book. Heather said, "What are
we teaching the young?" Nazism is a branch
of this historicism that has America in its
grip. Communism is a branch. The Confederacy
and its idea that slavery is good is a branch.
He showed me this book. This book was about
some little German kids with blonde hair going
into a butcher's shop. It's a little school
book, little kid book, colored pictures. The
butcher - it was a Jew - looked like Bluto
in the Popeye thing with stubble. Martin Gilbert
said ... I said, "Oh hi, what are you looking
at?", whispering. He showed me, and he said,
"Notice these sides of pork ... The Jewish
butcher is selling pork.
The story ... By the way, this book was edited
by the agency run by Julius Streicher, who
is one of the worst people ever to live, one
of the senior Nazis. He said, "Notice that
the ... The story was about the butcher killing
the Christian children when they came in,
the Aryan children, when they came in. He
said, "Notice that the skin color of the sides
of pork hanging are the same as the skin color
of the Jewish butcher."
We see that. He shows me that. I'm learning
that he's interested in that stuff. Then we
walk down to the London School of Economics
and we have coffee. He says, "Can I help you?"
I said, "No, I don't really need anything."
It's really stupid.
It emerged while I was talking to him that
I'd been reading his books. I could talk about
them. I'll give you a clue if you ever meet
authors or have a teacher, nothing better
than knowing their work. They really like
that. It's the reason the faculty is happy
at Hillsdale College.
Students pay attention and learn and hold
them in respect. It's an idyllic life. I had
that for him, but I didn't really want to
get digging in those papers very much. I said,
"But I'm here in London, and I will help you
in any way. Call me any time. I will look
up things. I will do whatever you want me
to do."
He looked at me puzzled, like I was a Martian.
He said, "Would you like a job?" I said, "Yes."
He said, "When could you start?" It was Friday.
I said Monday. I didn't say, "What would I
do?" I didn't say, "How much would you pay
me?" He said, "Good. See you Monday." He left.
I had to chase him and say, "By the way, where
should I go?" He said, "The Map House, Harcourt
Hill, Oxford."
"Oxford?" He said, "Yeah, the cab driver will
know where it is." "Oxford? Should I live
in Oxford?" He said, "That would probably
be better," so I moved over the weekend. The
lady who was managing the documents and the
correspondence downstairs kept making grammatical
mistakes. She wanted a permanent job, and
she didn't have one yet. He showed me one
of them, and said, "What's wrong with that?"
I pointed out what it was. He said, "Everyone
knows that?" I said, "I don't know. I know
it."
He said, "Do Americans know things like that?"
She had written slimming the tide instead
of stemming the tide. I said, "Well, I don't
know. I do." He said, "This lady will not
do," and he let her go. 5 or 6, 8 days later,
he arrived there to get coffee. He said, "There's
a new lady tomorrow." I said, "Oh, a new lady?"
He said, "Yes, she's very smart. 3 A levels
from Roedean." I said, "I'll look forward
to meeting this new lady." What showed up
was not a lady. It was my wife.
That's important because Churchill is important
because who is the greatest statesman? To
live in this bureaucratic age where the engineering
project to overcome man has become advanced,
Lincoln sees it in Colonel, in Seed, in the
Civil War. It's Churchill's theme all his
life. Churchill is on a battlefield in 1898
in Sudan. The Madhi of Allah, who is the grandfather
of the current ruler of Sudan, he founded
the first Islamic Republic as we know it today,
this Madhi of Allah, in 1895. That's when
he did that.
The current ruler of North Sudan and his cousin,
also a relation of this 19th century Madhi,
are the 2 chief teachers of Osama bin Laden.
Winston Churchill is in a cavalry charge against
these guys in 1898.
First of all, his life is the weirdest thing
you'll ever meet. He was everywhere. He was
captured by the Boers in 1899, and the future
president of the Boer Republic, Louis Botha,
was then the Region. Although he didn't capture
Winston Churchill, Churchill decided that
he did and would never believe whatever evidence
that rests to the contrast that anybody except
a famous man had actually captured him.
Churchill didn't like these Sudanese, Dervishes
they were called, but on the other hand, he
watched the modern weapons work on them, a
70,000 charge, 25,000 British. They lost 11,000
killed in about an hour. The one they got
nearest the British line came within 150 yards.
Churchill looked at that. You should read
the book called The River War, where he writes
about it.
He's a young guy, very much on the make. He's
demonstrating his heroism so he can elected
to parliament. He describes this battle. In
one paragraph, he describes the charge of
the Dervishes, whom he doesn't like, but he
says how brave they are and how the scene
for them is heat and bullets screaming and
people screaming and horses screaming and
dust and smoke everywhere, charging through
hell toward hell.
Then he goes back to the British, same paragraph,
and he says, "The infantry fired steadily
and solidly because although they could hardly
see the enemy, they still remained interested
in the work even if it became tedious." Soldiers
carried ammunition and others carried water
jackets to keep the barrels from melting.
Everybody moved like on a factory floor and
they killed 11,000 people.
Churchill has the imagination to ask, "What
if 2 armies come together both able to do
that?" In 1925, he writes of the phenomenon.
Mankind has never been in this position before.
Without enjoying wiser guidance or improving
appreciably in virtue, he's got into his hands
at last the means of his own destruction.
Death stands waiting at attention, waiting
for a word from the frail being so long his
servant, not for once his master.
We wouldn't be worried about these Islamic
terrorists. First of all, we shouldn't worry
about over much. The ones who are hostile
and do aggressive things, we should kill them,
but it's the possession of the worst kind
of weapons that makes it the most formidable
because they'll probably use them if they
get them. Their societies could never invent
those weapons, but once they're invented,
you might get them.
Churchill thought that this phenomenon that
we're becoming so powerful that we could destroy
ourselves. Churchill is 26 years old when
he first starts writing about this. As its
mate, in peacetime politics, Churchill comes
into the British parliament at the same time
as the Socialist Party comes into the British
parliament. He fights it all his life.
He said in 1945, "The socialists who have
been in coalition with me to fight the Nazis
could not realize their ultimate aims without
the use of a secret police, yes, I mean a
Gestapo." He said that after the war when
they had been fighting these Nazis. Of course,
historians are uniform in saying how stupid
that was and how it was a reckless moment
on his part. The truth of the matter is he
said that over and over again all his life.
He said it many times after that occasion
even though he lost that election because
I can tell you what he feared.
I'll read it to you. "Not the Bolsheviks.
There's not one concept in the philosophy
of the Russian Bolshevik which has not been
realized, carried into action and enshrined
in immutable laws a million years ago by the
white ant. Equally startling developments
lie already just beyond our fingertips in
the breeding of human beings and the shaping
of human nature."
If you watch the government acting now ... It's
been lawless for a long time. One of Churchill's
favorite things to say was, "If you make 10,000
regulations, you destroy all respect for law."
The new thing that's happened - it's emerged
just in the last 4 or 5 years - is that now
things are done in a lawless way that affect
the relationship between the government and
the people. That is to say that compromise
the ability of the people to influence the
government. I think they're calculated that
way.
Everything that tends to a control on human
speech, which is the central human gift, which
is the theme of the Obama administration since
the day it started, and everything that affects
who the voters are, so that the voters are
not picking who the voters are ... A government
that is thinking like that, that maybe the
people won't vote for us, but these things
are right to do anyway and we're going to
do them, that's the line that looks to me
like that's been crossed.
Now look at the tools that are possible in
the modern world. "Equally startling developments
lie already just beyond our fingertips," Churchill
writes this in 1931, "In the breeding of human
beings and the shaping of human nature. It
used to be said though you have taught the
dog more tricks, you cannot alter the breed
of the dog, but this is no longer true. Human
beings may soon be made, not birthed, but
grown under glass."
Churchill wrote this in the same year that
Brave New World was published, but we know
because he wrote his wife about that he didn't
read that book until 25 years later. He was
thinking, "We could interfere with the mental
development of the beings, who are now being
born or rather made, in a way to fit them
to jobs that we want them to do."
CS Lewis wrote that, "The power of man over
nature can only be expressed as the power
of some men over others." Winston Churchill
knew that too. What was his solution? What
he thought ... He left politics when he was
80 years old, and he'd been in more than 50
years. He thought all these things at the
start and at the end. That means that we have
a rich record of a genius about how to combat
these kind of politics.
In war, what do you do? Don't fight unless
you have to. Find a cheap way to win. Bring
into bear overwhelming force. Those are his
lessons. Strategy is his word. In peace what
do you do? Limit the government, enforce the
constitution, live under its limits. When
you provide the social safety net, which he
favored and hoped to invent, people should
invest in it. It should be a property that
is their own and that they can count.
In British times, they got stamp books from
the Post Office under the scheme he created.
The taxpayer put in 2 pence and the employer
and the employee put in 7 pence. Every 6 months,
they got their stamp book full of stamps and
they knew how much money they had because
he said, "The way you take care of the poor
is that they invest mainly in ways that will
give them a stake in the stability of the
capitalist system. They will not have the
taint of the dole because most of the money
is theirs."
"You can't have 10,000 laws," he would say.
In America, the 2 changes to the American
Constitution are the bureaucratic state and
the entitlement state. You get rid of the
entitlement state through savings accounts
that people own. That's Paul Ryan proposes
to do. You get rid of the bureaucratic state
by remembering that people are the best agents
to take care of themselves and there are plenty
of laws already and old about what happens
when you do something that harms somebody
else.
Churchill fought that war all his life. He's
been dead 50 years and a few days, and it
still goes on. What would we think? Should
we be like Larry Kudlow, an optimistic? Should
we be like Heather and pessimistic? Should
we be like Churchill?
Do you want to know what his last words were
in the House of Commons? In a speech about
nuclear warfare, "Never flinch, never weary,
never despair." We have his lessons, and we're
alive today and the fight is on. There isn't
any reason whatsoever that it cannot be won.
Thank you for helping.
Tim: Thank you Dr. Arnn. We have time for
questions. We have students with microphones.
Please wait for the microphones, and they
will bring the microphone to you.
Steve: Thank you, Dr. Arnn. Steve Barney from
North Palm Beach, Florida. Thank you again
for delivering the wit and wisdom that you
so often and generously give us. Thank you
for bringing Heather MacDonald here this morning.
She spoke with truth and clarity. At the end
of her talk, she pointedly talked about the
days when she was a student and she could
read any author, irrespective of their pigmentation
or plumbing arrangements and said you can't
do that today. I hoped you might have a comment
on that.
Larry: Thank you. That's the great Steve Barney
of the Barney Charter School Initiative. He's
very generous and very smart and a very good
principal, but his greatest single gift is
that when he gets sentimental, he cries out
loud. Churchill loved to say of himself, "I'm
a blubber baby."
The point is we are the subject of an engineering
project now. Here's the way we're regulated.
That thing, I've been hearing it everywhere,
and I think it may be true, that if you're
selling arms and ammunition, which there's
a right in the constitution and in nature
to do, then it's hard to get a bank loan.
The reason is the regulators are all over
the banks. All they've got to do is just raise
an eyebrow.
Reading is like that too. The government is
getting into the business of picking curricula.
The plan in the Common Core is that the courses
will go each course from Plato to Amy Tan.
There's usefulness in education to survey
courses that cover a lot of ground, although
that's a very great deal of ground, but there's
also usefulness to study ...
Do you remember what I said about Professor
Jaffa? He claims that he knew 3 books, and
he was a very learned man, very profound man.
When are you going to pick something great
that is really great and teach them what it's
like to know something great? That's banned.
We're not at the place now where some books
are not allowed to be read, although the adoption
of text books in America at the K12 level
is dominated by 3 states and they have politically
correct standards. If you can sell one of
your text books to one of those 3 states,
you've made a lot of money and to all 3, and
you're rolling. There's lots of controls now
in this centralized way of doing things. Whereas,
by the way, an excellent translation of Plato's
Republic can be had on the internet for free,
so why do you need all that?
It's been proved ... There's proof of it in
Texas and into Mexico because the schools
are old enough to have established some proof.
There will be proof of it, I predict, in 3
years in Naples, Florida, that any bunch of
idiots can start a charter school if they've
got the right idea about it and they work
hard and they can get spectacular results.
Why don't we have the freedom to do that?
Why is the bias not in favor of that? Why
is the college and why are people who start
these charter schools held up to public ridicule
and suspicion about all this? Why did it happen
in Bloomington, Indiana, not long ago, that
somebody said that Hillsdale College was not
fit to be involved in such a thing because
it was too conservative.
What is the thing that it wishes to conserve?
The beauty of human equality and the rule
of law and the culture and the arts that flow
from those things. If that's being bigoted,
then I very much am that.
Tucker: Tucker Anderson. I'm glad I finally
got to one of these after 25 years. Got to
see my friend Larry again. 2 related observations,
which I would like your comment on. First,
none of these are going to be pretty.
First, in fact, in several very important
ways, the ability of us to conduct the fight
in which we're engaged should be made considerably
easier by the interna- and by the thirst for
knowledge worldwide and not just the battle
in our country, but the battle on the worldwide
basis.
Second, in that regard, that it seems to be
very interesting how individuals elsewhere,
who have not had the privileges that we have
in a constitutional democracy, are so hungry
and interested in ideas which are being rejected
here.
Larry: Thank you. That's Tucker Anderson,
who has been a friend of mine for probably
more than 25 years, and a great guy. New Yorker.
The first thing about the internet. When I
first came to Hillsdale College a long time
ago, people would say, "Gosh, it's a really
great college, but what difference can it
possibly make? It's just a puny little place
in the middle of nowhere." I used to get that
argument all the time. I repudiate that argument
because learning has a way. The taking over
... A negative and a positive example.
Positive example, the schools were the leaders
of the American Revolution were instructed,
number about 10. The number of those key leaders
who were crucial to the job number about 150.
Others were important, but those guys, take
them away, different deal. Large numbers matter,
but also small numbers matter.
Negative example, progressivism came into
America from German historicism through Princeton
University and Cornell University in the main.
The numbers of people who began were like
10 and 12. Then it grew from place to place.
I repudiate the thinking that a small place
can't make a difference, but I don't have
to repudiate by that argument alone any more.
Hillsdale College has 650 or 700,000 people
who have taken online courses from it. How
many in this room? Lots. I get stopped in
airports now. It's a marvel to me. I can't
figure it out because class is really fun,
but since I get a lot of class in my life,
it wouldn't occur to me to watch a class on
a computer screen, but more than a million
times ... We think the upward potential of
that is in the millions, and it's still growing.
There's that and I'll hasten to add something.
It matters that Tucker and I have known each
other for a long time. It matters that we've
sat together many times and had a good talk.
I know his ways. I know he's proud of where
he went to school, all that stuff, although
it's too liberal for him. I know all that
stuff. Things like that matter. I'm married
to Penny, and we're not married on the internet.
We have a thing going on.
A classroom is a tremendous place. I want
you all to come because you should see what
a college is like when it's still like what
a college is like. One of the best things
I do in my life, apart from teach, is I eat
in the dining hall with the students. I sit
across from them and we're eating. We're in
our dining hall, and they know I'm going to
torture them. Also they tell me things, and
I learn things.
That means that a few people can do things
that very many cannot, but it's also proven
true, Tucker, that if somebody is really good
at doing things that a few people can do,
that can radiate everywhere and is doing.
There's great hope in that. I agree. That's
why it ticks me off so much that they took
a dramatic and lawless step to socialize the
internet last week. Let me just explain what
the step is.
We have built the fourth branch of government,
which is the regulatory state. It's much the
largest part of the government. The theory
that justifies it, if there is such a theory,
is that Congress and the president delegate
both legislation and enforcement to agencies
that specialize in particular areas. Those
agencies also enforce the rules they make,
hear disputes with their employees of enforcement
actions. They're the legislative executive
in judicial branches.
That's all legitimate because they're ultimately
under the control of the regular legislative
process and because no one part of the popular
branches, neither the Congress nor the president,
controls them. The number of people who work
in the state and federal is about 20 million
people. The idea is all divided up and there
are new kinds of checks and balances, but
what's not fully understood is it represents
a kind of government, a different way of doing
it, justified by different principles.
Our government, by consent, is justified by
the fact that we can talk to each other. We
have human souls, which is a reflection of
the divine soul. This kind of government is
justified by expertise and specialization,
the one who knows. Who should decide whether
20% of the income of the American people is
spent to relieve climate change? Should the
American people make that decision or should
experts make that decision?
It's an FCC thing. I read in Wall Street Journal,
the most powerful lobbyist in America, these
big telecom and technology companies, thought
they had this thing so that they weren't going
to do net neutrality, which is, by the way,
just stopping people from selling something
to the highest bidder. With one speech, Obama
turned it around and it's going to be done
in a month.
We know that Obama employed a man, who is
a law professor at the University of Chicago
and has been on the cover of GQ. My, is he
not pretty? Cass Sunstein is his name. He
says that the federal government should have
proper diversity on their websites, on the
internet. Is that what's going to happen?
The fairness doctrine for the internet? The
principles are laid down. Thank you Tucker.
Anybody else? Thanks. Oh wait. One more.
Speaker 5: It's a pleasure to have heard you.
My friend Biil Lomoth of 50 years has talked
a lot about you. I'd like to ask you a question
regarding the rule of law. When it was obvious
the Soviet Union was going to break up, there
would be 15 countries, places like Uzbekistan
and Pakistan and all those, which would want
to become democracies. For them to become
democracies, they take that sign on the wall
which said, "General Secretary of the Communist
Party, Uzbekistan," and turn it around. He'd
say, "Democratically elected President of
the Republic of Uzbekistan."
I began a conference. We'll have the 18th
one this year. We've had 1,400 chief justices
come and attend my conferences from 108 countries.
I ran into a problem. I was always able to
distinguish the rule of man and the rule of
law. The rule of man is you run an election,
you lose, you put 10,000 people on the street
and the try to burn down the building. That's
rule of man. Rule of law is you lose the election,
and you go to the court. The court reviews
the election and say, "Well, you're quite
right."
Now I run to a third option, the rule of Sharia.
I wonder if you could comment for us, who
are devoted to the rule of law, on how we
deal with the rule of Sharia, which is when
the supreme court of a country decides a case,
somebody appeals it to the Sharia court and
the Sharia court decides differently from
the court. Thank you.
Larry: Did you say Sharia court?
Speaker 5: Sharia law. There are Sharia courts,
as you know.
Larry: Yeah.
Speaker 5: The first comment I'll make is
if you've entertained 1,400 chief justices
from 180 countries, you, sir, have too many
chiefs and not enough Indians. The second
thing I'll say is the rule of law is a simple
and beautiful conception and a direction derivation
from the nature of the human being. All it
means is that the rules are general in their
nature so everyone can understand them.
There are just these steps. They have to be
made in advance so you don't know who is going
to be affected by them. Then they have to
be applied the same, generally the same in
all cases. That's a big order. That's very
hard to get that because where the rubber
meets the road is when you show up in court
and somebody knows Obama doesn't like you.
There's a whole bunch of people who are standing
outside calling you a racist.
The media is ready to repeat the charge and
waiting breathlessly for the verdict. The
attorney general of the United States has
threatened that if you're acquitted, you'll
be arrested immediately on a state charge,
on a federal charge. The rule of law means
none of that makes a blind bit of difference.
That's a hard thing to achieve. Nothing is
so precious.
The constitution of the United States is the
greatest protector of the rule of law in human
history and it is under assault. Everyone
must fear. One of my favorite things to say
in the last 3 years ... I said it in a board
meeting yesterday ... Is we have to remember
that we don't enjoy the protections of the
law fully any more. Now we have public opinion.
We have the good order of the college, the
excellence of its operations.
We have the fact that we don't take any money
from the government, which is a moral fact.
It used to be a legal fact. It used to protect
you because they couldn't regulate you unless
you took their money. Those are powerful things
and we rely on them, but they're not as powerful
as the rule of law. We fear and we wish to
restore the rule of law.
About the Sharia courts, it's a simple thing
to understand what's going on in the world.
What Larry Kudlow said was very artful last
night. He said we should refer to them as
totalitarian countries, but our country - and
by the way, it just so happens, Hillsdale
College - both are founded on the principle
of civil and religious freedom.
The reason the first amendment is the most
important of the amendments is that's the
one that protects the specifically human activities.
The second amendment is important. It has
to do with self defense and defense of the
nation, but you know a wolf can protect itself.
It just can't talk about it. It can't worship
its God, doesn't know what it is or what God
is.
That regime is beautiful because it recognizes
something essential in the human being. Also,
by the way, it makes sense under the dispensations
of both Christianity and Judaism. The reason
for that is Judaism is a universal religion
and a political religion, but it's not universally
political.
Only the poor Jews got chosen, and that's
a hard duty. Read the story of the Old Testament
and find out whether it's really a great privilege
to be the chosen people. They're given a law,
and only they are given that law. That means
that over them that law comes from above and
outside the political system. You can't appeal
against it. When God speaks, that's it, and
he does speak.
Christianity is different. It's a universal
religion, but not in any sense a political
religion. My kingdom is not of this world.
It tells you all kinds of rules of behavior.
It doesn't give any laws, and it doesn't appoint
any political bodies, no magistrates, no legislators,
no executors. That's one of the reasons why
Jesus was killed, by the way, because they're
impatient about that. They think they're going
to get a conqueror. He was not.
I'm no expert on Islam. I just happen to be
a fellow who can see. I know that, like Moses,
Mohammed was the general and a conqueror and
a ruler. I know that there is a law. I know
that this law coming directly from Mohammed
and therefore from God is said to be sovereign
universe.
That places the people who interpret it in
charge. If the Mullahs want a thing in many
countries, that is the thing that happens.
To appeal against it is to disobey God. That
means that that regime and the regime of civil
and religious liberty are directly opposite
regimes. That looks like then that there's
got to be a choice made. Like in so many areas
today, everything hangs on the choice.
Bill Lomoth has been a friend of mine for
15 years and I don't know a better man. Thanks.